what those characters are speaking isn't
gibberish it's actually a language
called dothraki and it was invented by
this guy david peterson in lovely orange
county california
david peterson is what we call a
conlanger an inventor of languages
conlanging is the intentional creation
of a full language creating its full
grammar its full phenology its writing
system if it has one and its entire
lexicon david has written many languages
but the first one he wrote was back in
2000 i was taking an intro linguistics
class at uc berkeley in 2000 and it was
just one day during class i started
scribbling on my notes my very first
language
he named it after his girlfriend meg
davey
and according to david himself it's
irredeemably awful it's just not it's
not worth even considering anymore
everything i was doing with this
language was just a kind of really fancy
bizarre way to speak english so i kind
of just started over and said all right
ground zero
how do i be a language creator
before we move forward let's take a
quick step back and talk about the
godfather of modern conlanging j.r.r
tolkien
you probably know this name because he's
the author of the hobbit and lord of the
rings
he created 14 different languages for
use within middle earth quenya and
sindarin are probably his most famous
he was the very first person that we
know of to create languages just for fun
and we've been kind of emulating him
ever since
now that we've cleared that up we can
move forward
we're here in california because we're
curious about what it takes to create a
successful language
david's having two of his friends who
are also conlangers come over and speak
with us one of them brought ice cream we
were gonna do this outside but it's too
hot so we're gonna do it inside
the three of them are talking about how
languages are created
and they've come up with five steps
take it away guys
[Music]
so all right a naturalistic online needs
five basic things
one
the people what they do who their
neighbors are the second thing that
you're going to need is a phenology or
sound system do you have voiced and
voiceless consonants do you have
aspirated consonants three
words all the nouns all the verbs all
the modifiers fourth
grammar which is the fun part
finally
history you need to know how the
meanings of words changed over time and
you need to know how the grammar of your
language evolved from a time in the
distant past to what's used now
now that we've got that settled let's
finish this
in the past 15 years somebody who
created language went from somebody who
was like oh you're a nerd too you know
oh wow um that's that's really nerdy
which now means cool
and it's prolific use in television and
film proves that it's not just a passing
fancy
[Music]
for television the difference between a
created language and some other set prop
is that the maximum level of interaction
that a viewer ever has with a background
set or with a prop is just seeing it on
screen a language on the other hand uh
when you hear it that's the that's the
most real a language ever gets for that
reason you have to have a fully created
language for a television show and not
just a bunch of gibberish
was that good sounds great thank god
hello normally when you think of words
they fit into a language
but there's a relatively new class of
words that don't quite follow the rules
and it's called wasellego
[Music]
john kelly is a language writer i spend
a lot of my time writing about word
origins he's a linguistics expert and he
knows just about everything about the
phenomenon called waseigo
wasse ego literally means japan made
english it is a language process that
takes foreign words
usually english words and transmogrifies
them into something wholly new and novel
for japanese purposes
we see this with a word like karaoke
everybody knows and everybody loves
karaoke but it joins the japanese kara
which means empty and okay which is a
japanese rendering of orchestra so a
karaoke is an empty orchestra the most
popular example is the word pokemon the
creator of pokemon took two english
words pocket and monster he smashed them
together and got pokemon or take cosplay
a word that describes people dressing up
as fictional characters cosplay joins
costume and play and there's anime anime
is a fairly straightforward rendering of
the english animation quasi hugo is
important because language is always
changing and reinventing itself what new
words will pop up in the future only
time will tell
is
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
is
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
my name is ianni sikonoma i'm from
greece and i speak 32 languages russian
portuguese norwegian turkish hungarian
czech police ionis is what we call a
hyper polyglot
it means he can speak a lot of languages
by the time i was 20 i'd already learned
some
15 languages and
when i moved to brussels and started my
career at the eu institutions i added
more official eu languages see the thing
is i honest he's
[Music]
this doesn't happen by just sitting at
home and studying
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
the world is a big place with different
cultures and yes different languages it
cleveland living in murder in sprague in
other talent
marinetal i speak to my husband in
polish because he's polish i dream in
all kinds of languages
[Music]
before we go if anyone knows it's you
what is the most complicated language to
learn
mandarin
mystery solved
uh
[Music]
all right that's the way it happened
[Music]
good
[Music]
oh
[Applause]
[Music]
so
[Music]
so
[Music]
so
[Music]
you